you know in life this hazers going live
are we actually going live all right
okay it says we we're live
all right cool and we're live and hello
and welcome to round table with the
stream team and this is where we talked
to amazing content creators about their
journeys of where they are and what
they've done and and you know how or how
they're doing today
as you could tell last week I was super
sick didn't sound like it at all this
week
I'm feeling better but now my voice is
gone so I would like to welcome tonight
to our roundtable chairman foo he is an
amazing content creator that I have
known for years Jer how are you doing
Jeremy I'm doing what else I wanna do
thank you so much for having me on it's
this is great to be here great I'm happy
that you were able to you know you know
chisel out some time and your stream of
schedule I know you and I we have very
similar streaming schedules that we are
during the week so it's kind of hard to
be able to do that but I really
appreciate you you know doing that for
us absolutely thank you and we we have
l-boogie use you're with us this evening
how are you
we're doing fantastic right you the
avatar
I'm loving it I love that avatar was the
first thing I said when you popped on I
was like I love it
that's great yeah I got to take that in
Rittman so oh nice nice good you go one
of the campus huh campus beautiful and
Jays the boss is out sick today he must
have done too much partying this weekend
yeah College look college life for you
he gets you real quick and old-school he
said is gonna be coming in and he's
gonna be coming in while we're starting
he had a last minute engagement okay
someone had a birthday party and he did
not know so he is he's on his way
mmm so jameth um why don't you tell us
where you started becoming content
creator and why you decided hey I want
to do this and you know create this
amazing community
and I have so many questions and I sure
I I'm telling you this is this is gonna
be interesting because I've known you
for so long and I can finally complete
you and I face to face so we're gonna
we're gonna be talking for a while so
good no problem tell us tell us about it
sure sure so I've been I actually kind
of discovered twitch I came to twitch
late to the party as it were um a buddy
of mine at work years ago probably if
we're gonna put some dates here maybe
2014 said hey look there's this cool
platform it's kind of like YouTube but
it's live and you can interact with the
Pete with the content creators and so
forth and like wow this sounds pretty
cool
cuz I I was a big youtuber back then
watch Let's Plays and things like that
so started watching twitch and really
just fell in love with the platform and
I'm like you know what one day I want to
do this I should just do it and so I
started doing some research and yeah
February of 2015 I decided you know what
it's gonna do it I took a couple of
weeks off from work um first week we
went to Disney World
had a good time with that and then the
second week I'm like okay I'm gonna take
this week off and I'm just gonna and of
course I had to get get permission from
the boss my wife and she was by the way
has been great boss who she's been great
with all this very supportive oh yeah
so so she was she was good with it and I
started in February of 2015 and I really
had no idea what I wanted to do I want
to do it I just I love people I love
interacting with people I love video
games I'm like you know if we can just
combine these two let's just do it you
know
so um started streaming and when I
started off I Roy didn't have any kind
of direction or anything like that I
started off of streaming pretty much
every day for the first six to a six to
eight months even if it was just a
couple hours here and there and and at
the time I was working shift work um I'm
a retired police officer for just to let
everybody know and so I was working a
lot of shift work back then and that
that made it very difficult and when we
got around that and so I got to
point where I'm like you know what I
love playing video games
we tried actually focusing in on on
individual games for a while I played a
lot of Final Fantasy 14 for months on
end I actually started with EverQuest
which was one of was my old-school MMO
that I started with way back in the day
and had some good success with that had
some good successful Final Fantasy but
I'm the type of person if I play one
game over and over again
I get burnout Lu kind of alluded to that
earlier when we were talking for the
podcast and I just can't do that
then and which gives me so much respect
for the streamers that can do that god
bless some man because that is an
incredible amount of discipline and and
drive and self motivation to be able to
stream just one game all the time so
anyway I decided you know what I'm just
gonna be a variety streamer
you know and as you guys may know
probably you know it's it's tough as a
variety streamer it's not of you I know
you know that oh yeah it's hard to build
a community but first and foremost I
think you have to really enjoy what you
do because if you don't enjoy what
you're doing nothing else matters you
know it does none of the other stuff
matters so so I've been doing that ever
since and we've gotten built a pretty
pretty good community I'm very happy
with the community we have and we're
still you know still going so that's
pretty much where I'm at and what I came
where I came from so when you started it
was one there was 14 approximately well
14 was when I when I discovered twitch I
actually started streaming in February
of 2015 15 yeah so I kind of met you
probably closer to the start of your
twitch career so to speak mm-hmm and
when you started streaming there didn't
seem like there was very many viewers
but all of a sudden there was a huge
ramp up in your community so what what
do you think that kind of can attest to
that
because you have a great community the
fantastic that your discord is like
poppin all day long I had to use MJ's
word he's not here had to say it once
good so yeah yeah no I and I appreciate
that and I gotta tell you I am - what
you said I I love our community it's
it's very very active some great people
for sure um but to your question you
know you know what's interesting because
I I don't know if I can pinpoint one
exact thing you know it part of it I
think it I think part of it is we
started we started streaming with some
consistency and and that helped of
course but I don't even think that's the
biggest contributing factor um I was
very fortunate to get a handful of
really good community members in when we
first started streaming and they started
showing up pretty regularly and I think
part of that is right place right time
but I think also part of that is the
community fed on itself you know um it's
it's hard to say you know um maybe maybe
part of it is is is the games I picked
again playing Final Fantasy a good bit
at the beginning another game that I did
I even mentioned I played a lot of
Marvel heroes which was a in you
familiar with Marvel heroes yeah and
fern maybe any of your listeners who
aren't it's kind of like a UH a diablo
style a RPG with the marvel universe
it's shut down now sadly but but that
had a really good community and there
was a point there where i was streaming
that for for months on end because it
was just I'm a big comic fan and so that
kind of just we found a groove there and
and a lot of people just kind of kind of
like-minded people started started
coming into the community and then
sometime later we we built the we built
the discord and I'm the type of person I
am probably to my detriment at times I
am always on social media you know and
so I
I'm always active in my discord and I
think that helped and we had people
coming and coming along there and so it
just kind of fed on on itself you know
and it's it's I don't know if that's a
good answer but it just kind of it's
hard to play it put my finger on one
specific specific thing you know yeah
yeah so when you how should I wear this
so when you start you said you're kind
of like you love social media you kind
of like into it so to speak so what
platforms are you and then not being on
all the time mostly Twitter and discord
now um I used to be used to be on
Facebook a while back and I just I got
so tired of the toxicity you know it's
just I I believe I believe in positive
thinking and and just in what's
interesting is Twitter's kind of gotten
to that point too but I problem but I
digress
um and so I got to the point where I was
like you know what I just I just had
enough of Facebook so I don't really get
on Facebook anymore don't get me wrong
there's a lot of good on Facebook too
but but I kind of got away from that so
mostly Twitter now and discord um but I
use Twitter mostly to keep up with the
community but to also um keep up with
like gaming news and things like that
because it's it's it's amazing how that
is the best way really to get your news
instantly you know and and for real news
you got to be kind of be careful with
that but for gaming news it's really
really good you know
yeah really found out there like Twitter
was where it was at to get late like as
soon as possible gaming news absolutely
and I'm sorry no no no you're good I was
just gonna say and that's and else point
that's that's kind of like where I
really started getting deep diving into
social media and keeping up with it
throughout the day you know all week
long and that kind of thing you know do
you find that um
Twitter be is better for engaging
or the buzzword for the Year Engagement
to your community instead of other types
of instead of using discord or Instagram
because I've kind of noticed Instagram I
find more people coming in and out of of
being able to get more followers and
more people watching and hearing my
channel bless you and then instead of
Twitter or you know or discord and I
kind of feel like is that do you find
that Twitter's better for you or discord
for the engagement yeah you know that
and that's a good question because it
social different social media platforms
different people use them differently
right so so Twitter while I do use it
for a little bit of dissemination of
information I mostly use it for
information gathering and the occasional
Twitter post you know going live or or
when you find something some really good
information I'll comment on it or and
elaborate on it things like that but I
use it mostly for information gathering
whereas discord I use that mainly from
my engaging and my my most of my
information dissemination and keeping
the community up to date on what's going
on and things like that you know the
second time I've done that like oh my
god I'm like pressing a button and I
guess I press it twice
so then it means me right after I start
talking Oh anyways I think that like
Instagram because it's such limited
interaction that it's easier for people
so more people are inclined to do
Instagram than Twitter because you'd
have to be most people tend to be more
talkative right Instagram you can
literally just like someone's stuff and
that counts you know what I mean sure
yeah no that's a great point that's I
actually have my community manager Fox
magic you know him um I have uh I he's
been bugging me to get on Instagram so
I've actually been thinking about doing
that so I should probably do that but L
you make a good point because Instagram
is more that instant gratification right
right you can just get in get out
whereas Twitter it's more even a Sony
only like two hundred eighty characters
whatever is it's still you just diving
in and relay links and things like that
yeah for sure
so I've been using this application
called HootSuite and I tell people this
all the time it works out really really
well I literally on Monday I do all my
posts for the week and I'll do pictures
I'll do events and things like that I
need to use it and it just pops out
everything you only yes it doesn't auto
post to Instagram so what I end up doing
is I end up having none of my phone I
got my notification on my phone I'm just
like open Instagram to boom bang bang
boom and I'm done cuz I do it I use I
use it for ILP I use it for a roundtable
I use it for my own Twitter and I own my
own marketing stuff it's so much easier
than having to do it on a consistent
basis or you forget it solely just like
you have that that visibility whereas
this caused $0 same goose egg trust me
goose egg what's it going HootSuite
HootSuite yep it's really really good
interesting so chair chair while you're
while you're looking at booth sweet mmm
so you're a huge Marvel fan a huge comic
book fan in general now two to two
questions one how did you decide your
intro that comic book intro mm-hmm so
how did you decide to do that yeah and
how did you know that like Marvel heroes
was gonna come I felt like that was your
niche
like that was that was a really really
big game that I'm sure that's remember I
was asking before we came I thought you
kind of like blew up on I thought that
was like your game yeah for sure and to
your first question the the the video
intro was actually created by two of my
mods by Fox magic and unstable jester
and we were looking for something an
intro video that that would be number
one unique and number two kind of
encapsulate what our community was about
and so they they came up with that I
gotta get I gotta give them the credit
for that because they were the ones that
came up with it I don't in love with it
and because it's you know again as you
said I'm a huge comic Marvel fan but it
also it also has still shots of some of
the different different games I played
over the years and it shows that hey
this guy's a varieties trimmer so when
you come into the stream you see oh cool
Comics Marvel action but he also likes a
variety of stuff too so it kind of gives
you a snapshot of what our community is
about you know um so so that um that
right there I got like I said I got a
give I got to give them credit for that
now as to your second question for
Marvel heroes yeah you know it's it's
interesting because that I don't know
what it was and some streamers will tell
you different different games were you
know that was the one you know and I
guess that was the one for me and it's
kind of sad that it's gone now which up
I'm really looking forward to Marvel's
Avengers next year we're gonna have to
keep an eye on that um so but um yeah
when when I started playing Marvel
heroes a lot of people I've noticed I
noticed I was getting a lot of unique
views a lot of unique names coming in
and it was it was enjoyable
banner in with them back and forth not
only about the game but just about about
Marvel heroes Marvel Comics and lore
overall and I guess because I was so
passionate about
that you know maybe that's part of the
reason why why it felt like it blew up
as much as it did I got to tell you man
it's an shoot you guys know this you
guys are streamers so you know but being
passionate about what you're streaming
is so important you know you have to
love what you're doing you have to enjoy
it because if you don't it's not it
that's gonna trans try and translate to
your community they're gonna know that
they're gonna see that you know so um
yeah I would say that that was that was
the big thing just just my enjoyment my
passion for it and it it was a game that
had a really good community you know it
was a really strong community overall
and I think that helped you know so I
would say that dozen of those were big
element oh I'm sorry I don't know no no
no it's uh I'm gonna blame the
robitussin yeah so when you started to
like the whole streaming process you
said you took time off and you kind of
like went out and bought all the
equipment
did you like literally like go
soup-to-nuts like straight from the top
got a great microphone that great that
said can you tell you know like inform
us more of that sure sure
no and I didn't go crazy all out at
first because I thought was one of the
things that I that was that when I did
my research ahead of time I a lot of the
things I was saying was don't go crazy
don't go out and buy hundreds of dollars
worth of equipment um I did get a new
computer but I I was I was due for a new
computer anyway um and so I had a new
computer and just it just coincided with
the time that I would be getting it
anyway um and I got I got a capture card
I did get that and I got a large
terminal um I started off with the
external elgato hd60
is the one I got originally I use an
abra media internal one now but up so
and then I had a I just
got like a I did get a mic but it wasn't
a real expensive one it was like a like
a 30 or $40 mic you know nothing really
fancy and I had headset and that was
pretty much it and I went with that and
that over the years I kind of upgraded
piecemeal here and there I got I got my
audio Audio Technica
mic that I'm using now some point along
the line I got a I got a sound board
things like that you know so I yeah I
kind of kind of pieced meld it together
at first and then over time add it on
you know you said which internal car did
you have now um it's the avermedia
internal HDS is there a reason why you
went that route or well I when I when I
was doing a research
um the avermedia had just through the
research that I got like L said a lot of
people seem to like it yeah and it it
when I was looking to upgrade my my
capture card obviously internal
was better because of the response rate
and and so forth so I went with that and
I've enjoyed it it does a good job ya
know so you have all of the Funko pops
in the background yes yes I have to ask
which comic books are those that you
have which spider-man comics because
I've know I've never noticed you
actually had actual comics back there I
only saw the Funko problems so which
copies the spider-man are those ok so
what's interesting is these were all
from most of them most of Myr I was I
was subscribed to the Marvel collector
Corps for a while and so I was getting
them as a part of that one of my
spider-man pops is from the original
spider-man homecoming it's it's the
spider-man homecoming outfit I've got a
Miles Morales spider-man hop up there
which is really cool I've got a Morbius
which is which is one of spider-man's
nemesis you know and the other ones were
just there's one I've got one with him
in his traditional blue and red but
nothing nothing from a specific coming
and bless you but uh yeah so those those
are the mains I got a couple of
Deadpool's I know Elle's a fan of
Deadpool I've got a couple of us
spider-man comics back there too scum on
my so my my pride and Joy's I've got the
spider-man comic that has the first the
first appearance of his black costume
which is really cool and I've got
another one amazing spider-man 122 which
is the the issue in which right after
Green Goblin killed Gwen Stacy and I'm
sorry I'm getting off town a tangent
here but that was that that was a
massive that was a massive story point
back in the days because that in the 70s
killing off main characters was not a
big deal like it didn't happen that did
not and so that was like a revolutionary
point in Marvel and in spider-man
specifically so that when that one cost
me a pretty penny to pick up but uh it's
nice a little bit of my my spider-man
memorabilia back there my my friend he's
he's huge comic book fan and we actually
we went on an adventure in New York City
Comic Con one year to find him his first
edition seeing of the puncture because
he's a huge Punisher fan and I can't
tell you how many different vendors we
went to and we eventually found him but
oh and it was it was like a full day of
hunting through comics for him and he
finally found one that was perfect
condition that he bought it and one that
wasn't in good condition
so he could read it so it was an
adventure in a really amazing thing well
I finally I remembered what I was gonna
say before okay we have someone named
King David on the Iron Horse podcast who
is huge into statues and figurines he
has this thing called king of statues
you would love it because he puts on
Marvel DC
all different figurines of every single
genre and I'm talking like these are
beautiful like handcrafted statues Oh
like is that you you'll really
appreciate so when you get time you get
you gotta go take a look at them
absolutely that sounds amazing yeah
they're really really cool yeah yeah
I'll check it out how how do you how
does your family feel that you are like
kind of a strict on this schedule
because you used to have like like an
everyday schedule from what I remember
when you were when you were pushing
partner and I know you're still are
technically pushing partner we're always
not pushing you know you know what I
mean right so well but like how did your
family feel was there any was there any
issues with that or were they like very
like or supportive or how did that go
for you yeah so um my daughter is
starting to practice let me shut my door
real quick no problem sorry about that
yeah my brother's a French horn player
and so she's practicing which is good
but I don't want that to come through on
your on your podcast so um no I yeah
it's it's that was good timing because
um actually my family always comes first
always my wife and my daughter always
come first
and I I would not be able to do this
without support of my family because
it's just it being a family man it just
would not it would not work you know so
first and foremost I had to get that go
ahead and okay from from the wife and
she was fine with it and we talked about
it at a time and we said look no matter
what happens if there's something
important in a family's life or in my
daughter's life growing up I'm going to
be there hmm I am going to be there and
so that's actually come up a few times
here because my daughter is in the
marching band at her high school for the
aunt Oh
Friday nights I have to miss some Friday
night streams and so you know it's never
a question it's always the family first
other than that it's the wife knows that
that if if it's a Monday through Friday
and I'm full so stream I'm gonna be here
you have to
you know in in my in my opinion if if I
want to make a living in a career out of
this one day I've got to live the life
live the career before I achieve the
career yeah I've got to treat it like
like it's something important I treat it
like it's a job and I don't mean that in
the bad sense the bad connotation of the
word I mean it as in all the
responsibility that goes along with that
if if I'm supposed to be at work at a
certain time on a certain day I'm going
to be there you know and so that my wife
and I are on the same wavelength on that
and that's one of the reasons why it's
true Monday through Friday because I I
take the weekends off and I and I just
immerse myself in the family and what we
have going on here and and that's all
for them and then um you know like I
said occasionally during the week if
something comes up it's a family thing
daughter has a concert or an event then
I go and do that but I always try to
make that up to the community in some
way you know so
yes the Sabbath on it's definitely a
Razors balance that you have got to find
you know for me anyway for me personally
yeah - fun do you find that L do you see
that also okay like I know well I can
come back because you were talking about
how you make sure that it's family first
which for me like I feel like I have to
push family to understand that I'm
trying to do this mmm so like for them
because my mother and my sister my
father he's supportive but my mother and
my sister they are so far removed from
the video game like industry and stuff
like polar opposites like they're more
into fashion and like what do you want
to say like landscaping things like that
like my mom is like a big garden area
she has like this crazy Martha Stewart
being your type garden but oh yeah
so you know we like totally different
things so for them they're just like
come on come do this with us you know
they don't really like understand that
I'm really trying to like make like a
little community here yeah
and that's that's fascinating yeah you
know and what's interesting and of
course I guess I'm I'm a little odor
older of course I'm I'm the old man so
my parents are yeah yeah my parents are
in their 70s and so it's interesting
because I've I've I've had a family for
a while man I'm kind of on my own do my
own thing mm-hm and my my parents are
very supportive of this it's it's ironic
actually because there are times when
we've had family get-togethers with them
mm-hmm and I'm like look I I would love
to be there but I can't be there because
I work I work tonight and they
understand you know they understand um
now if it's a weekend thing I'm there
you know so it's but I've had other
distant I don't know secondary relatives
I guess you could say cousins and things
like that who who I could tell are kind
of like mmm I don't know
interesting interesting note yeah cousin
who a little off tartan tangent here but
I I have a cousin who is a video game
developer he's actually got a game on on
the Nintendo did Nintendo WiiU store and
he also is an artist so it's like I
can't even like say who he works for
yeah yeah that's awesome Wow yeah so so
it's kind of like Uli I have some family
members who who are get who get it they
understand they're into it and then
others while they may not necessarily
say anything you can tell they just
don't get it you know great what about
you Pete I'm kind of lucky like in the
beginning my my parents kind of they
didn't understand the whole concept of
what was happening and then one day I
actually took my dad and I was like this
is what I do
and I showed him and he goes I don't get
it as long as you're enjoying you're
fine and my I'm lucky that my my wife is
she's amazing
she's a she's a rock and she supports my
crazy streaming and all the podcast
stuff and and all the stuff that I do
she's amazing I couldn't do half this
stuff without her more than half the
stuff without her and I mean I'm kind of
lucky I do I didn't trust one thing
though I stopped posting when I went
live on Facebook because I actually
noticed that a lot of my family members
and friends started on friending me and
I was like that's a very interesting
point that they didn't they didn't care
about me before but all of a sudden they
started on friending me just because I'm
posting that I'm going live and I'm
doing this and I said hey I would like
some help I want you to come and lurk in
my channel and then they started
unfriending me and I was just like well
if that's how you feel and then I
actually did a Facebook purge and I just
took out 90% of everybody on my Facebook
page and it was just now my core family
and friends that I know that are gonna
always have my back no matter what
because it was very surprising to see
that like ants not ants I'm sorry like
cousins and you know uncles and things
like that not uncle's like you know
uncles removes and so to speak but it's
like you know I'm like I'm not dealing
with this I have enough stress in my
life I don't have to deal with it okay
yeah but all in all it's pretty
interesting like different people act so
different like outside of our little
bubble you know when you start telling
people this is what you do it's like you
have people like oh that's cool what I
started doing was is I actually start
now when I leave the house
I'm always almost like 99% of the time
always in a twittery
and some iron Lords podcast shirt or a
style of the TV shirt or twit shirt and
I leave the house I always have my
business cards I mean because I never
know who I'm gonna walk into and I've
ended up like handing out cards and now
I have like actual people that I know
that actually come and watch the channel
or people from work because like my wife
is a she's an amazing artist so she does
ink box tattoos on my arms pretty often
not right now but like people will see
like emblems for videogames you'll see
like the division symbol on my arm or
they'll see something and they'll be
like oh what is that do you play video
games is that Assassin's Creed and like
yeah and they're like what do you learn
and then I go into the whole entire
explanation of it where I then end up
starting to give out business cards to
them so like I almost always have a
mommy yeah it's pretty interesting you
know it's you know what else is
interesting is and I thought about this
when you were talking about your your
Facebook experiences with with your
distant relatives and friends and things
like that it's fascinating how a lot of
times in this in this circle of twitch
YouTube those kind of communities we we
have people who have never met us in
real life yeah who who are so good about
coming in and supporting us on a nightly
basis and yet people that we've known
our whole lives a lot of those people
don't take the time of day to do that
isn't that fascinating no I was just
gonna finish by saying it's it's it's
I've heard the saying before I think you
know something like and don't take this
the wrong way I'm not saying I'm a
profit or profits or anything but do you
get the idea that that a profit is never
appreciated in his own land yeah you
know I don't have ever heard that's
saying it's it's true but it makes sense
if you if you if you build up something
in in the neighborhood and around the
people that you grew up around they just
see you as little Joe from down the road
or a little Daisy from down the road and
then other people that you build a
community with they view you in a
different light not not better or worse
but they Ville you differently that's
how they know you you know so it's it's
just it's fascinating how that works so
I've got a great story I have a great
story mm-hmm so one of my closest and
best friends and I will say that he is
one of my best friends I've met
twice in my whole life I met him playing
world Warcraft like he in oh four we met
and we became like instantly like really
good friends exchanged numbers texting
back and forth he ends up calling me up
one day and goes Yelp I need you to do
something for me I'm like what's up
Jacob what's going on hey guys I need
you to be my best man at my wedding and
I'm like I've never met you in my entire
life I'm like I will make I will make a
deal with you I'll come to the wedding
I'll be a groomsman I will be there for
you no matter what but I cannot justify
being a best man because you know just
just in case god forbid something
happens because like he lives in
Cleveland I live in New York I was like
something happens I don't want I don't
want that responsibility to come down
and I'm like who knows what happens in
20 years because it's the gaming life
you know you'll be fine now but in like
two three years it's all over and I mean
I've known him like I said since oh four
and we still talked daily to this day so
and we've only seen each other twice and
he's a great guy and he's one of those
people that come into my stream all the
time and support me it's like hey what's
going on
what's going on let's go do something
let's go he's great and that is just one
of those amazing things that you know
that's really cool
it absolutely I mean we we are building
relationships with people that will last
a lifetime you know and I think I gotta
tell you man that is I think that is one
of the toughest things about being a
streamer in my opinion is this right
here is you build these relationships
and I view each person in my community
I'm sure like you guys do too
they're family these people are family
to me we build these relationships and
but but but unlike other family if they
can't show up for a couple of weeks
couple months whatever it that's just it
is what it is they have wild lawn and
you can't and then sometimes you have
these family members
that will just stop showing up hmm you
don't hear anything from them and that's
fine that's fine because stuff happens
they have lives whatever but it it goes
against everything that you feel should
be for family and it's tough as a
streamer because you get so close to the
people and it hurts and I don't mean
that like bad on them because I get it
man not everybody I'm for twitch I mean
people families people get new jobs
people get family with sickness or they
have illnesses and look I get it but
it's like that's what makes it so tough
because you have to accept that as being
part of a string method you're gonna
have family members sometimes that drop
off and you will may never see them
again
that's the part about being a streamer
you know in my opinion yeah so let's
change your subject in a little lap
you're right no that's fine no it's I
love these I love these types of
conversations and I can and I could talk
about this all day about that stuff but
let's like I said that's changes to are
you planning on going to twitch cons
here or you or any of options yeah
probably not I I do need to make it to
twitchcon one of these years it's just
it's so tough with my new with the job
I'm working at now and just with
everything else it's hard to get time
away to go to some of these conventions
uh I would like to do that I would
really like to go to twitchcon at some
point you know that's that's my goal is
to make it a twitchcon yeah yeah like
you never even have a thought in your
mind about like going like in III or
PACs or any of those but it's not for me
oh no if I had if I had my choice man if
I had the means I would go to all of
them all right
oh man there'd be so much fun I it's one
of those things where I need to kind of
choose you know because I know I'm not
gonna be able to have the means to do
all of them or even do a few of them so
my the twitchcon is the one I would like
to go to at least at least at first
and then I maybe decide on some of the
other ones later so might my hope is I
would like to try to make twitchcon next
year but I don't want to make yeah I
just want to make a commitment on that
books I don't know how things are gonna
work out you know yeah yeah yeah it's
it's it's kind of hard because I know
like for me I do one convention here and
99.9 percent of the time it's PAX East
cuz I just take the train from New York
to Boston it's perfect for me I don't
have to really think about it and it's
my kind of way to get away and it's kind
of like Elle she really took get me
wrong like you enjoy going out III like
that's like that's like your thing like
I feel like everyone has their thing
like I see it used to be down the street
for me it's not on the street anymore oh
wow yeah she decided to move from
California to Virginia difference just a
little bit yeah well I was here before
so now boss foo and daughter foo uh-huh
now do they end up gaming at all or is
that just an internal thing so so boss
foo
not really I will start talking geek
stuff with her and video games and she
just starts rolling her eyes and so I do
it on purpose to kind of just to kind of
get a funny look if I remember you know
so she's not really a gamer she she has
in the past actually played played
Diablo 3 with me and she kind of likes
that game a little bit she can deal with
it daughter fool games but it's like
casual stuff you know like she plays
little games on her phone yeah things
like that and then so I remember one day
she came home and she's like daddy can
we can we download fortnight like what
do you know about fortnight oh and
apparently I guess because you know her
all her friends at school played I'm
like all right meanwhile download on the
PlayStation for you but I mean you're
probably not gonna like it
I don't know and she being a being a 13
14 year old girl she probably just wants
to see what her friends are doing and we
did she played like one time and that
was it you know but yeah so so kind of
casual you know yeah yeah so you have
like you have like family like board
game nights or anything like that or we
yeah we do actually we haven't done them
recently just because the schedule has
been kind of crazy daughter Foos had a
lot of like marching band competitions
the last few months but we used to get
together like every weekend and we want
to kind of get back to doing this and
we'll do like a game day and we each get
to pick a game and we played some DC
deck-building Game legendary which is
the Marvel version of deck-building we
played a deck building game called Clank
things like that boss who and I'll play
some settlers before some of the Catan
things like that um and every everyone
small will get on the PlayStation and
play like overcooked super frustrating
yeah I played that with my wife you know
what I've never heard her curse like a
sailor more than that when we ever
played overcome awesome so good it's
such a fantastic game and like I'll be
sitting here and she'll be sitting here
we'll play on the computer and like I
have to like defend myself because like
shoal arms will go up and I'll buy I'm
gonna get hit because I was gonna happen
but yes she she's but it like she's
really good when we're really organized
so it works out really well with two
players but yeah oh man I love that game
for multi both for multi family stuff oh
my gosh so many times we'll find
ourselves just rolling on the floor
laughing literally our stomach hurting
so bad and so we're getting mad at each
other because we're laughing so hard
that we can't do you know cuz you got to
work you guys know you have teamwork in
that game and so one person is slacking
on their job because they're laughing so
hard and then the rest of us are yes
yes oh my gosh yes so fast what'll end
up happening is like you know that
there's a couple of those maps do you
have like ice in the middle you have to
like move across one nice thing and then
it slides yeah so there's there's a
couple of times we're all like purposely
like Ram into her into the water just an
aggravator
but like she's such a perfectionist like
we have to keep going at the same level
until we three-star it so it's like oh
oh I'm talking like repetitive yeah and
we did it for the first one in the
second one oh it is so much fun but and
so it can be yes yeah we when you're
trying to three start it can be it can
be brutal yes so um for tech building
games there's a couple of really fun
ones five-minute dungeon me and my wife
ended up picking it up fantastic
quick thinking game we weren't able to
do with two people we were only able to
complete it with four people that's
really really a good game if you ever do
have that Harry Potter heart it's so
good but it's so hard with two people
oh man we've started getting progress on
it because we invited some friends over
and we do for person and we expansion
packs will be a balloon uh now also so
we have a fifth person as an option but
it is it did so many it's so good that's
really good really really good abour
game yeah I would think that there are
quite a few board games or deck-building
games board games that are that are
really challenging to with just two
people you know um legendary which is
the marvel deck building game actually
works really well with two people really
it does yeah you can actually play that
when they didn't solo it's obviously
more fun with two two three four people
whatever but it works really well with
two people which is nice I've heard
galaxy truckers is another one I don't
have I don't have it play galaxy trucker
supposed to be really good hmm
mark somebody's down and look him up
later trust me I have a I have a little
you know a little filing cabinet me or
board games and things well we'll go
over it and when like when I go up to
pax like they discount everything it's
so nice that I'll go up there and I'll
come home with like five or six board
games I'll like give one to my parents
once my brother and sister-in-law once
and my niece and the rest are me and my
wife's and we don't have it we're like
we don't have any room anymore so I
gotta get a box or something start
putting some stuff in storage or
something yeah yeah
LG do you have any questions so do you
never do any shows I think I don't know
if we asked you but do you ever do any
shows with your daughter shows like
oh screaming oh yeah yeah well she's
actually it's interesting because um I
actually got her on one day on Twitch
sings cuz she's a she's a she's an
incredible she's got an incredible voice
my whole my whole family and boss food
boss was pretty pretty musical too voice
wise and my whole family has a musical
background and so so daughter food got
that got that family and so she I got on
do uh yeah I I uh actually I'm average
singing but I I was a trumpet player I
was in the LSU marching band and I grew
up uh you know playing trumpet most of
my life so that's for my musical talent
ladies I played trumpet in middle school
and then I primarily played cello when I
went to high school and I was actually
in the choir in the Navy oh wow now
that's cool um so yeah yeah so daughter
Phuket
she did a uh I remember the song the
song from frozen the Minuteman oh let it
go let it go thank you I had a mental
block I knew it
so she did that and she did an
incredible job with that but but to
bring that back to your original
question that's pretty much the only
time she's ever really gotten on camera
boss foods are really really a little
has sent a little tentative about her
being on on camera and doing a lot of
stuff and I get it I understand you know
but yeah so that's that's pretty much it
but she enjoyed that we had a good time
with it you know well I do occasionally
do a stream with my daughter we do like
a little Mommy & Me so when you said
that no I can't think of it we're just
like okay not even a pair of threesome
this today because we cannot remember
our words but I know what is it the
cooking in-game we were just talking
about overcooked yeah so we'll play that
she wants I don't know why she wants me
to stream with that game probably
because she knows that I will behave
stream that sometimes yeah cool yeah
yeah that's awesome
I gotta ask the the food addicts so how
did you how did you come up with that
name for the for the community for for
all of us crazy foon addicts if you will
cuz I am Bob you know I'm there I'm one
of those guys that's in there once in
seeing what's going on so how did you
kind of think of that as the kind of the
name and in the community building yeah
so that's a good question
um I kind of you know when I when I
started swimming in the in the community
started growing I was talking to the
community I'm like what are we gonna
call ourselves and and so they people
were throwing things out and one person
throughout the Germania acts and I'm
like I don't like that because it's just
I don't know it just made me feel
uncomfortable you know I don't so I I
want it to be about the community I
don't want it to be about me so much you
know and so we through we were talking
many different things and and talking
about how the community is fun and
upbeat and everything and somebody said
somebody mentioned we're fanatical about
our fun and we're like food fanatic foo
net food addicts how about food addicts
and so you know and it kind of goes
along with food and food and so it kind
of just evolved you know that's kind of
where that
came from yeah so this is German food
like the specific like a nickname of
yours from like high school or whatever
or from school or where did that come
from
no so so yes I know what your first name
is right and I don't mind telling that
everybody and I think most of my
community knows now but my first name is
Jeremy and so it actually came from that
was a nickname or not even a name it was
actually a character name that I used in
an EverQuest way back in the day I was
just trying to think of a name and I got
tired of trying to think of something up
and I was like well this uh German fou
you know I don't know I just kind of
kind of brainstormed it and so it stuck
with me
and I started using that for twitch yeah
yeah but it's kind of similar to like my
name like everyone's like where did you
come up with snell dough from and I'm
like it was a randomly generated name
from Star Wars Galaxies that no one ever
has and you want to know what it kind of
just sticks and the best part about it
is is like when I go into channels and I
had this conversation with a respawn
when he was on here and he was like no
one can ever pronounce your name and I'm
like yeah but people will always
remember me because they never can
pronounce my name so it's a nose weird
double I'm sort of like their likes
Nellie's now uh snow smooth snellie
dough snack you do like I'm like snail
dough just called me Sonali it's fine
like it kind of over time people just
remember your name from yeah well that's
good to know because I've been
pronouncing it wrong all this time I'm
sorry it's fun oh yeah when I the first
time I ever was on the iron Lords
podcast with the guys they asked me to
like how the heck do you pronounce your
name so I said it's pronounced Naldo
no one ever pronounces it right just
call me Pete that's my name just call me
Pete cuz you want to know it that's what
everyone calls me any like so it does
there you go so works out really really
well love it yes L do you got anything
else you can think of
yeah so I'm gonna I'm gonna ask you the
the last question that we always ask all
everyone that's always on to the show if
you could live in one video game fantasy
world what would it be
um for instance like Harry Potter or
Marvel or like EverQuest World of
Warcraft you know is there type of world
or you could end up you know living for
like you know forever yeah and do you
mean as in living in the and in in the
world itself or being a character in
that world cuz that's two different
things right if I'm a little nobody in
that world but that doesn't mean you're
nobody like you you never know you could
you could be like Captain America right
right right you don't know what it would
be like sure so like you know that
taking taking those specifics out of it
like yeah like I would love to live in
the world of Harry Potter
being able to use magic waving a wand
would be awesome I'm not saying I want
to be a muggle I don't want to say I'm
not saying I want to be Harry Potter
yeah you know I just want to be a guy
that can use managers to be able to like
if I spill something on the ground I
want to be able to use magic to clean it
up cuz I won't last you want to clean it
up right well this is this is probably
not gonna be a lot of a lot of drama for
this because my community probably
all-in-all knows what I'm gonna say but
it would definitely be Marvel that's
gonna be the Marvel world you know to be
to be a Marvel hero in there somewhere
would be would be pretty amazing another
world that would be pretty cool but it
might be we'd be pretty gloomy and dark
is the shadows of shadows of Mordor or
shadows of war that that would be pretty
cool to be a tell adore V there be the
ranger but then that's a pretty gloomy
world so I think with Marvel did you
ever complete the shadows of Mordor I
did I beat shadows of Mordor and I beat
shadows of war shadow war yeah those
games are so good yeah really like I
love those aspects of those games those
stealthy type games
like the original Sanskrit X Games and
when they decided to take that and bring
it into the world of Lord of the Rings I
was just like I'm in this is it I'm good
I want to do like because so good yeah
it's I love that type of you know
environments and and seeing the worlds
it's so good yeah
did you play the Lord of the Rings
Online I did not and there are a couple
of our community members who who have
been suggesting that to me and I know
it's a little long in the tooth now and
it's just later in its lifecycle but I
I'm gonna to check that out at some
point so I played it when it first came
out and it was really good and it's more
of a pay2win type situation now which
isn't fantastic but if you got into the
game early on they had a like spend 50
bucks and you have a lifetime
subscription so like if you ever want to
go back you to play and you know what
it's still really really good and it's
still something that's kind of an old
its own it feels more like the graphics
of an EverQuest which I know you just
assertively wouldn't mind so if you go
back and you look at it it's good and
you can get a whole bunch of people in
to play with you because it's you know
the beginning part of for it is free
yeah maybe let's check that out yeah
tough tough to do so definitely do so
mm-hmm so so what why don't you go ahead
and tell us everybody where they can
find you times and and all that fun
stuff
sure um so my twitch channel is
twitch.tv slash chairman foo it's je RM
a in fu and I'm usually online streaming
Monday through Friday 7:00 p.m. Eastern
to 11:00 p.m. Eastern and then once a
month we do our community Sabbath on
which is usually on Saturday it's
usually this first Saturday of the month
although sometimes like this month we
have to push it back so but um but yeah
that's that's my normal stream time I
want Twitter at chairman foo gaming and
that's a non discord yeah those are my
my my social media areas that's that's
where we can find you that's it
Elle how about yourself well I've kept
the same schedule for a few things I'm
on mixer Tuesday through Friday at 6
p.m. Eastern and yeah you can find me
there on Twitter it's Elle Baguio 208
pretty much on Twitter all the time so
fantastic and just given a couple of
quick little shout outs to the rest of
the panel members so MJ's a boss as as
you guys know he is living the college
life he is MJ as a boss on Twitter and
you know he is on twitch on the same
name
go ahead and check him out I know that
he's trying to get a schedule together
but I think his fraternity life is now
ramping up again so he will be back in
the saddle for that soon if I may real
quick Arielle what's your what's your
mixer username on its own buggy oh 208
okay so it's the same Twitter it's it's
everywhere mixer with Twitter I even
have a youtube but I don't post okay and
then we have old-school style who's our
you know our other a member who must
have gotten stuck out for a little bit
longer than not expected he is on
Twitter mixer twitch and also he has a
channel called old school Tech Talk
where you guys can go there and get some
really amazing information about new
technology that's coming out he really
tries an honest production value so you
guys really should go check him out I
would like to also say thank you to the
gentleman who for coming you're
fantastic I really appreciate you coming
thank you
it's been great to be here we pretty I
pre yes thank you so much thank you very
much
I am Snell doe SN a ly do I am on twitch
you can also look me under snow there's
our TV
you know bring you right to my twitch
page make it real easy for you so I am
on Twitter I'm on discord all the time
you guys know where to find me I'm there
I want to thank the guys from lords of
gaming net that is our website they do
some amazing amazing work we just
brought on another amazing editor who is
going to you know who's gonna do some
amazing things on that website so I
really want you guys to go take a look
at that iron Lords podcast is you know
that our I guess brother-sister company
if you will quote unquote yeah they are
on sundays at 11 o'clock they are
booming they are amazing I want you guys
to go check them out they're fantastic
we are the roundtable with the stream
team we are here usually every Monday
next week is Veterans Day we are taking
the week off
yes we are the week after that we are
not on Mondays we're to be on Tuesdays
we're bringing boomstick XL here he is a
fantastic guy he could not make Monday's
so we're gonna have to kind of tweak our
schedule all around for him and we
wanted to make sure he was here he's
done so much stuff for us
so we want to make sure we can show a
little courtesy to him to make sure he
is here on Wednesday morning you will
wake up and we are going to be on all of
the podcast platforms we are on Google
podcasts we are on iTunes we are on if
you name it we got it Spotify we are on
there oh when I put the link out on
Twitter it is for our anchor page which
allows you to go anywhere in all of our
podcasts different platforms I think
we're even in whatever the Tesla car
thing is so I mean we're all over and we
are on Twitter is table stream table
stream yes I had to write a note because
it is ridiculous I'm I can't ever
remember it so if you want to go there
you'll see when we go live our guests
are notations all that fun stuff is
there if you guys have any questions for
any of our guests please email us at
roundtables stream team at gmail.com
thank you very much
greatly appreciate once again chairman
foo you are amazing I am happy that you
were able to come and hang out for a
little bit thank you for my honor they
know it is it is our you come on join us
I really appreciate it and remember
everybody to dream big
and keep on playing thank you again hi
everybody